on Thursday word emerged that a Patrick
Chung born on the same day as the
Patriot Safety Patrick Chung had been
indicted in New Hampshire for felony
cocaine possession and by the later
hours of the morning it was clear that
it was indeed the same Patrick Chung
indictment on charges that could in
theory and you always hear the worst
case scenario of the potential sentence
but three and a half to seven years that
is a significant punishment felony
charge Chris and you know the immediate
reaction was well this guy's not going
to play this year well that's not how it
works for offenses that fall under the
substance abuse policy this is not a
personal conduct policy issue this is
not a commissioner exempt list situation
where the league can suspend him with
pay nothing happens on this until the
charges are resolved and we know how the
legal process works it takes a while for
this to work through I think it's a
practical matter unless the Patriots
want to do something with Chung the
league's not gonna step in he'll be
available to play all season long and I
think this is something that gets
resolved most likely after the 2019
season still a serious situation right
but to the extent that people think he's
just gonna disappear that's not how it
works under the substance abuse policy
yeah it is it is funny as far as I'm not
that loophole but how it's a different
set of circumstances there I heard you
say that on radio right before we came
on TV and and went oh gosh you know I
kind of forgot that that particular part
of it first off I'm shocked that it
happened on June 25th and we're just
figuring finding this out I mean that's
shocking
a Super Bowl safety Patrick Chung who's
been a big part of that Patriot team for
so long it's amazing you could stay
quiet for this long other thing is I
just want to ask you this what does a
Class B felony you know did he have a
huge brick of cocaine what does that
mean do we know any of those details or
was it just a little for personal use
that's where I want to ask you a little
bit about it every state's got its own
formula for what level of a felony
something is but obviously the higher it
is the closer it is to a the bigger of a
deal it is which implies that that
there's more than the usual normal
amount that expect to find on someone
now it's not so much that they presume
an intent to deliver okay right right
but but I have to get into the nooks and
crannies of New Hampshire law to really
understand that the bottom line though
is if he's guilty he's looking at a
potentially significant sentence but as
far as his NFL career is concerned he
should be able to continue playing for
all of the 2019 season until at some
point after the year most likely this
thing gets resolved in court and a
suspension would be imposed and you know
we're looking at at maybe four games
maybe a little bit more than that
so it's you know now unless he's
incarcerated then obviously he's gonna
miss all of them but for this year
Patriots fans I think you as long as the
team wants him he'll be available in all
the fans of all the other teams that
want to be thrown out of the league
that's not how it works we'll see how it
all plays out
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports